you know people say that doing a PhD
changes you as a person on basically
every level right psychologically
emotionally physically you are different
what I'm trying to say is I have a beard
now so we're coming into the last few
weeks of the PhD mail and things have
been getting very hectic and very
stressful recently so you have to
remember that most PhDs have at least
two supervisors right now the main
supervisor and then you have a second
supervisor that's you see less
frequently and there like a check or a
balance on the system and I recently
showed my thesis about hundred pages
long it's still not complete yet - the
second supervisor and the reason
everything has been particularly
stressful recently is because basically
he disagreed with the direction that my
main secret eyes were taking with the
project and didn't feel comfortable with
me submitting as it was so what that's
meant practically is I've basically had
to rewrite the whole thesis you'll have
to excuse the slightly shoddy audio I
left my microphone in the office you
might have noticed by the way that I
have some writing advice from my
supervisor on my desk the cat sat on the
mat because basically that's the style
of writing that you want it what rather
he wants to see in a thesis it's got to
be simple it's got to be subjective and
to the point well one of the big
problems with my first draft was that I
was trying to write it in a way that was
a little bit more poetic I guess like
trying to use fancy language and like be
more it be inappropriately evocative so
today I basically finished rewriting
chapter two which is the background
chapter and I'm completely
psychologically exhaustive like trying
to bear in mind the entire PhD worth of
background across loads of different
sort of sub sections trying to keep it
all up in here and all the intricacies
to debate my supervisor my own axiom and
you know changing 40 odd pages of
anything and either adding appendices
adding in closer II like all this stuff
is just like it's a lot at once
fortunately today is Monday which means
that I actually get the evening off
recently I've been working from 9 until
8 kind of thing I yeah
I've been pushing it quite hard recently
where as it's currently six
I've just finished and now got to go and
do some stuff over there in town you see
that all focus cathedral thing where I
was really small when it's far away that
might be the dumbest thing you've ever
so
[Music]
so we just did the San Martin's concert
which is what we do every week it's like
a short little choral music I think I
actually fell asleep in the middle of a
solo I was doing like I have no
recollection of like four or five notes
I'm really tired
[Music]
but just a like 800 calories of pasta
because I was too tired to make anything
else like tortellini not not just like
spaghetti so just pop home and have
dinner because I'm cheap well and also
very much money um because I'm only
going out again to engage in little
tradition the downline we're doing for
the last couple of weeks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks ed so there's this bomb in extra
called Holland rule which is which is
very out-of-focus apparently and
basically they can showing Game of
Thrones every week this is not improving
I'm not pretty dodgy patient surveys
that they done on I've been coming here
for the past couple weeks to watch Game
of Thrones with a crowd of E as you can
see behind me is pretty kings of Game of
Thrones E in there anyway dams also here
we're gonna watch that game
[Music]
unfortunately we both have this ruin for
us because of internet so we knew it was
going to happen in the end what is some
of them I knew well we knew that we knew
about the drag no one tells me nothing
this episode I cannot Christ elections
the finale hand and she walked away
she's been hurt by too many men in her
life but she doesn't have a field and
that's touching on issues that game of
thrones hasn't done before and it's AA
man down more emotionally compromised
sweaty working a lot
now would you look at that it's time for
my audition so I'm here in Cornwall
house this is a remote anything I've
shown you before because I've not been
in here before
this is one of the upstairs rooms
because I can't get into the downstairs
rooms because my student card doesn't
work anymore so I am here to take a
break from work to eat lunch and I'm
actually doing something I haven't done
for quite a long time which is some sax
practice sax s a X no not no not I
forgot I have to do something else
bollocks so basically I forgot I was
meant for taking some pictures so that's
now done that was really quick
[Music]
so it is currently half-past eight I
stated no for so long the camera I was
doing a time-lapse and it ran out of
battery so yeah I pushed it kind of hard
tonight because I just kind of hit a
groove I was rewriting chapter three
which is my theory chapter based on the
feedback I got from my second supervisor
about the background chapter and it's
amazing that now I look back on what I
thought was good and the way I was
supposed to write it and go oh god it's
so obvious what I was opposed to do um
so I think really really hope that when
I show my supervisor he's gonna be like
yeah yeah you've got it now you get the
idea I'm really quite tired they're like
a really really fit it's always a
difficult balancing act to try and
strike between pursuing the work to the
degree in which you know you can like
tonight I knew that if I just kind of
kept going I was in like a weird fuzzy
kind of space where I really just wanted
to kind of keep going and I don't know I
wasn't getting distracted I wasn't
getting bored I just kind of kept it
kept going at the same time I know that
if I push it too hard I won't be able to
work in the future I want to burn out so
I thought the reasonable cuts off was an
11 hour working day also in truly
historic news for the PhD the big run of
inverting 35 I think it is years might
be more of potential vorticity the the
big code that I was sort of building
everything up to that's now done it
finishes tonight and I was like right
okay let's just make sure that's saved
the note that's in that's in Dropbox so
one of the things I'm going to do
tomorrow morning is to take the output
from that and actually use it to to get
the variable which I'm looking at that
might take more than a day to calculate
though I'm not well I've not done it
before
okay I'm just about to go in weird gay
so I've got a meeting first thing about
my thesis rewrites I then have a bunch
of programs to run on the output of the
inverter and a little bit more coding to
do you on another well whenever it is
related another related project and then
I'm coming home at lunchtime for reasons
which will become clear to the meeting
went fine this morning I'm basically
talking about you know the protest
making with the thesis the original look
through the output of the inverter means
that everything's come up physically
I've got a program which I wrote to
check how accurate it inverted it you
know comparing it to observations that
look great you know very happy with that
the initial statistical look for it it's
like yeah your hypothesis doesn't work
at all which you know it's fine a null
result is still a result it's still
something you can write up in the
science paper and say you know we tried
this it didn't work
don't try this I'm still valuable to
know do we Barrett it were they so I was
just packing up my things to get a home
and I realize I have a pizza in my bag I
bought pizza on Monday and I just
totally forgot about it because I put it
in the bit of my bag which has like a
laptop in and not the middle of it where
I put I don't know like I bought ketchup
and stuff I doubt but I've just been
carrying a pizza with me for the past
two days
so obviously of things very intense at
the moment and over the course of the
past I think five weeks
I took one day off like even working
weekends as you saw yesterday they're
very long days and it has been I'm a
level of tithe I don't know if I've ever
been before this is approaching what I
felt like you know it Oxford finals so
it's important to take care of myself
which is why I've come home and give
myself half a day off this week and you
may ask
why on Wednesday or not on the weekend
but there's two reasons one I worked
better on the weekends like when there's
no one in the office office some reason
I just seemed to really really work well
secondly though just because it's a day
off doesn't mean that I stopped working
so recording the wiki cast which is
dialyzed podcast which has gone really
surprisingly well
like yeah we're in the charts for
podcast which is nuts
Walker alright ready to record but I
need to borrow this microphone because
it's I'm just here to explain all right
campaign and the podcast is done I'm
gonna have fun editing that one there's
quite a lot of material to work with
this week fun discussion though um if
you are not a reader of the podcast then
definitely check us out on sponging on
that recording or podcasting service of
choice we've started recording
separately which is why I was in my room
and Daniel was in the nook under the
stairs in my neck whoof so because I
have the best girlfriend in the world
you know
so because I had the best girlfriend in
the world I mean I objectively not live
knows what I'm going through obviously
like a lot of work at the moment with
the PhD and so she has sent me a graze
box which I'm absolutely mauling this
video is not sponsored by Jake right but
actually if great wanna sponsor me and
send me more please do it got some
poppin corn
oh yeah you've got a afternoon infusion
with a Chia coconut cookie uh-huh uh-huh
Chia
can you leave Dibby Dibby tattoo this is
tops thank you so much live so with the
podcast done it's now five o'clock and
this reveals the last reason why I wants
to take my half day off this afternoon
it's gonna take some explaining so my
favorite livestream
Dan's got the remote to the TV this is
gonna work out so well my favorite live
stream every week is Louis and Ben save
the world which is two people from the
Yogscast playing a really old game
called XCOM and I absolutely love it and
I was really keen to watch it this week
because they take donations from their
audience and if you're lucky you'll get
a soldier named after you and the idea
is then everyone gets really invested
and like your soldier I like to point
out who they all the soldiers in the
game has a very low life expectancy um
like you know people get really behind
this I all Simon's just coming up the
wall now and I got role I got in and I'm
actually a minigun it's not like a
really important person on the team a
super super excited to watch at this
week and probably watch myself die
except it turns out that um it turns out
that Lewis inventor away so we're
watching admittedly some of our other
favorite youtubers playing a different
game
feelsbadman Lewis and Ben why please at
least I have some amazing snacks
courtesy of pixel girl and Dan Scott is
amazing lamb curry no but normally
melancholy no okay and okay hat films
you want to collaborate with us there's
no boys do it right so live streams over
and I'm back in my natural habitat
editing so I've been editing for the
past five or so hours I'm not sure how
long it's been and there's a rough cut
now done of this video which must be
hour by the time this comes out they
make a video where and Lily did down a
nice makeup now it was my day half day
off you might wonder why I spend
however many hours at spin editing and
the honest answer is yes I mean it is
technically work I do for YouTube but I
really like doing this and especially
when it's a project as fun as this it's
just a joy to edit it's it's so I'm so
lucky to be able to do this kind of
video actually it's not very often I get
to do it with my friends I mean we're
basically just pissing around and it's
it's so much fun to relive honestly
friends are really important in like
getting you through this kind of thing
and I think editor editing in a way is
almost like you're capturing friendship
experiences do you can play them about
whatever you want it's quite a powerful
thing also powerful however is sleep I'm
just gonna get a sleep on that mattress
on the floor now see you tomorrow
you